Nowthen, Minnesota. Population 4,400, November. The city council met to figure out if they wanted to continue getting police protection from the county sheriff. It would cost them $105,000 for a year. And lots of people showed up to say that they thought it was a waste of money in a rural area like theirs. One woman got mad at the sheriff for suggesting that they needed all the police patrols and all the 911 calls they had been making.
Nowthen，明尼苏达州。人口4400人，11月。市议会开会决定是否继续聘请县治安官提供警务保护。这每年将花费他们10.5万美元。很多人现身表示，在他们这样的农村地区，这纯属浪费钱。一位妇女对治安官感到愤怒，因为治安官暗示他们需要所有的警力巡逻和他们一直在拨打的那些911电话。
You list 1,300 calls per year. And you say things like, a cat in a tree. Oh, my god, I saw a coyote. I've got to call the police. Oh my god, I saw a dog I don't know. I've got to call the police. What portion of those 1,300 calls were actually crime related? It feels like you're trying to scare us--
你列出了每年1300次报警。你说的是像“树上有只猫”这种事。噢天哪，我看到一只土狼。我得报警。噢天哪，我看到一只我不认识的狗。我得报警。这1300次报警中，有多少是真正与犯罪有关的？感觉你是在试图吓唬我们——
Not at all.
一点也不。
--into thinking we're in the new crime capital of the North.
——好让我们以为自己身处北部新的犯罪之都。
I showed you all the numbers we have. I showed you the burglaries, I showed you the assaults, I showed you the thefts.
我向你们展示了我们所有的数字。我展示了入室盗窃、袭击和盗窃案件。
I understand that. But that adds up to less than 300. So, 1,300, 300.
我明白这一点。但加起来还不到300起。所以，1300起对300起。
If it'll make you feel better, we have 300 crimes. I'm not sure where you're going. I'm not trying to scare you.
还有有条件的“愿意”。
No, I'm not, I'm not.
不，我不是，我不是。
I'm just presenting the facts.
我只是在陈述事实。
I'm just saying that--
我只是想说——
Springfield Illinois, 2009. Illinois state police do away with their new motorcycle division, thanks to budget cuts. As a result, more residents die on the road. Annual highway fatalities in the state climb from the low 900s to the high 900s.
斯普林菲尔德，伊利诺伊州，2009年。由于预算削减，伊利诺伊州州警解散了他们的摩托车分队。结果，更多的居民死于路上。该州每年的高速公路死亡人数从900出头攀升至900多。
Well, it's extremely disheartening.
嗯，这令人极其沮丧。
That's Jonathon Monken, who ran the state police when the cuts happened. He says that in his first three years, the motorcycle division had been a huge success, drove the number of highway deaths down to what they were in 1922.
那是乔纳森·蒙肯（Jonathon Monken），在削减发生时他负责州警察局。他说，在他任职的前三年里，摩托车分队取得了巨大的成功，将高速公路死亡人数降到了1922年的水平。
I mean, a lot of people worked extremely hard to drive those numbers down. And that's just frustrating when you see increases of 20, 30, 40. And obviously, when you're dealing with fatalities, increasing by one is a bad thing. I mean it's something that you don't want to see happen.
我是说，很多人付出了巨大的努力来降低这些数字。当你看到数字增加20、30、40时，这令人沮丧。显然，当你处理伤亡人数时，增加一个都是件坏事。我是说这是你不希望看到发生的事情。
You would think that the very last thing that a city would cut would be police protection. That's one of the most basic things we want a government for. But of course, in this recession, police are on the chopping block in a way that they have not been in decades. And beyond police, over 600,000 state and local government jobs have been slashed since 2008.
你可能会认为城市最后削减的项目就是警务保护。这是我们希望政府存在的最基本原因之一。但当然，在这次经济衰退中，警察正面临几十年来未曾有过的裁员威胁。而且除了警察，自2008年以来，超过60万个州和地方政府工作岗位已被削减。
And at some point last year, after the showdown on whether the United States was going to raise the debt ceiling to make room for more spending, which of course, if you remember, came after one of the many regular showdowns on repealing the Bush tax cuts. And it came before the December showdown on payroll taxes and unemployment benefits.
去年某个时候，在美国就是否要提高债务上限以腾出更多支出空间的僵局之后——如果你记得的话，那是在关于废除布什减税政策的众多常规僵局之一之后发生的。而且它发生在12月关于工资税和失业救济金的僵局之前。
Around that time it occurred to me that as a country we just keep having the same fight over and over again. There's one group of people who believe that the size of government is a real problem, and who think that we should have a smaller government that delivers fewer services and costs us less in taxes. And then there's another group that doesn't think that. Maybe they're not exactly happy with everything government does, but they are not looking for real downsizing.
在那段时间里，我意识到作为一个国家，我们只是在不断地进行同样的争论。有一群人认为政府的规模是一个真正的问题，认为我们应该拥有一个规模更小、提供服务更少、税收成本更低的政府。而另一群人则不这么认为。也许他们并不完全对政府所做的一切感到满意，但他们并不寻求真正的规模缩减。
And these two sides just go at it, over and over, fight after fight, political cycle after political cycle. And usually we don't really talk about the underlying question behind all those fights, which is, what kind of country do we want? Do we want a bigger, taxier United States of America, or do we want a smaller, cheaper United States of America?
这两派就在那里不断地对抗，一场争论接着一场争论，一个政治周期接着一个政治周期。通常我们并不会真正谈论所有这些争论背后的根本问题，那就是，我们想要什么样的国家？我们想要一个更大、税负更重的美国，还是想要一个规模更小、成本更低的美国？
Well, today on our radio show, we bring you three stories where people not only try to answer that question, they put their answers into action in their own cities with dramatic results. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
好了，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们要为您带来三个故事，人们不仅试图回答这个问题，还在他们自己的城市中将答案付诸实践，并取得了显著的效果。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, The Sound of Sirens. So let's start in one of these battlegrounds, in a state that is enacting sweeping austerity measures. Where the governor has not only held the line on taxes, he hopes to cut them further. This is New Jersey. As a result of these budget cuts, the city of Trenton laid off 103 officers from its police force in September-- that's a third of their force-- with serious consequences. Sarah Koenig visited them.
第一幕，警笛声。让我们从这些战场之一开始，在一个正在实施全面紧缩措施的州。州长不仅控制了税收，还希望进一步削减税收。这是新泽西州。由于这些预算削减，特伦顿市在9月解雇了103名警察——这占了他们警力的三分之一——并产生了严重的后果。莎拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）拜访了他们。
One great thing, maybe the only great thing, about the budget cuts in Trenton, is that you can park anywhere and not get a ticket. I parked in illegal spots. I ignored meters, even parked directly in front of City Hall three different times. And I was fine. Thieves, drug dealers, carjackers. Apparently they've sensed the same thing. That maybe no one's minding the store.
预算削减带来的一个好处，也许是唯一的好处，就是你可以在任何地方停车而不会吃到罚单。我把车停在违规地点。我无视停车收费表，甚至三次直接停在市政厅前面。我都没事。小偷、毒贩、劫车犯。显然他们也感觉到了同样的事情。也许没有人管事了。
17 robberies for this week. Out of control.
本周发生了17起抢劫案。失去控制了。
This is Sergeant Mark Kieffer of the Trenton PD. He's been a cop for 16 years. His father was a cop. He clicked through some recent crime stats on his computer.
这是特伦顿警察局的马克·基弗（Mark Kieffer）警长。他当了16年警察。他父亲也是警察。他在电脑上点击查看了最近的犯罪统计数据。
We're having anywhere from 15 to 20 robberies a week. We used to have five robberies a week. We used to have eight detectives in the robbery unit. Now all we have is two there.
我们每周发生15到20起抢劫案。我们过去每周只有5起抢劫案。抢劫组过去有8名侦探。现在只有2名了。
It seems that if you get rid of one third of your police force, crime tends to go up. Most alarming to Kieffer, the shootings.
看来如果你解雇三分之一的警力，犯罪率往往会上升。让基弗最担心的是枪击事件。
In 30-- what's it today, the seventh? So in 38 days, we had 32 people shot. We just had two people shot yesterday. I'm talking 32 people hit. That doesn't happen like that.
在30……今天是几号，7号？所以在38天里，我们有32人被枪击。昨天就有两人被枪击。我说的是32人中枪。这种情况以前从没发生过。
Usually, what's it usually?
通常，通常是什么情况？
Maybe once a week you get a shooting. Yeah. Once a week. Not every day.
也许一周一次枪击案。是的。一周一次。不是每天。
From January, 2011 to January 2012, gun assaults are up 76% in Trenton. Robberies with a firearm are up 55%. Car thefts more than doubled. Break-ins more than tripled. The Trenton Police Department no longer investigates thefts, including motor vehicle thefts. They also got rid of their domestic violence unit.
从2011年1月到2012年1月，特伦顿的持枪袭击案上升了76%。持枪抢劫案上升了55%。汽车盗窃案翻了一番多。入室盗窃案增加了两倍多。特伦顿警察局不再调查盗窃案，包括机动车盗窃案。他们还撤销了家庭暴力部门。
Back before the cuts, the Trenton Police were holding crime at bay. It still wasn't great. For a city of 80,000 people, Trenton had a pretty high rate of violent crime. But other crimes were decreasing. Now the cops are losing ground. And average people are feeling it, and not just in a "I read it in the newspaper" kind of way either. Almost everyone I talked to in Trenton had a crime story about someone they knew or about themselves.
在削减之前，特伦顿警察还能控制住犯罪。情况依然不算好。对于一个8万人口的城市来说，特伦顿的暴力犯罪率相当高。但其他犯罪在减少。现在警察正在节节败退。普通民众感觉到了这一点，而且不仅仅是以“我在报纸上读到”的那种方式。我在特伦顿交谈过的几乎每个人都有关于他们认识的人或他们自己的犯罪故事。
The other day-- did you hear about the shooting last week? Well, I was there. You know what happened to me, don't you?
前几天——你听说上周的枪击事件了吗？嗯，我就在那里。你知道我发生了什么事，对吧？
That's a guy named Richard who didn't want to give his last name.
那是理查德（Richard），他不愿透露姓氏。
What happened? What happened?
发生了什么？发生了什么？
We had to dive out in the street over here when he went by. I hit my head on the curb.
他经过时，我们不得不躲到街上。我的头撞到了路缘石上。
Wait. What happened?
等等。发生了什么？
Drive by.
驾车扫射。
Richard's lived on this block for 50 years, and nothing like that had ever happened to him before. One guy told me a bullet went through his office window, right where he sits. Another told me about a woman he was chatting with at the bank, who told him she'd just been mugged, at 10:00 in the morning. Another told me about a fatal shooting on Route 29. And then he told me the guy who was killed was his brother.
理查德在这条街上住了50年，以前从未发生过这样的事。一个人告诉我一颗子弹穿过了他的办公室窗户，正中他坐的地方。另一个人告诉我他在银行聊天的一位女士，她说她早上10点刚被抢劫。还有一个告诉我29号公路上发生了一起致命枪击案。然后他告诉我被杀的人是他哥哥。
I heard this stuff in the so-so neighborhoods, and I heard it in the good neighborhoods. Didn't matter.
我在普通社区听到了这些事，在好社区也听到了。没区别。
There's been muggings, and there's been shootings.
发生了抢劫，也发生了枪击。
Right here?
就在这里？
There's been break-ins. Yes.
发生了入室盗窃。是的。
That's Marge Caldwell-Wilson, a Trenton city councilwoman.
那是玛吉·考德威尔-威尔逊（Marge Caldwell-Wilson），特伦顿市议员。
We had a rash of burglaries. During the day while people were home they were stealing copper downspouts and running down the street as the neighbors were yelling at them. So that's how brazen things are happening.
我们发生了一连串的盗窃案。白天人们在家时，他们偷走铜制落水管，然后在邻居们的叫喊声中沿街逃跑。事情就是这么猖獗。
In this neighborhood that was happening?
是在这个社区发生的？
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
I keep asking if she's talking about her neighborhood, because her neighborhood is beautiful. Historic Victorian townhouses, lovely clean streets. I saw a Volvo station wagon parked across from Marge's house, two car seats in back, a New Yorker magazine in the passenger seat.
我一直在问她是否在说她的社区，因为她的社区很美。历史悠久的维多利亚式联排别墅，漂亮干净的街道。我看到一辆沃尔沃旅行车停在玛吉家对面，后座有两个儿童座椅，副驾驶座上有一本《纽约客》杂志。
And this isn't just happening in Trenton, which was the last city in New Jersey to lay off police, by the way. Camden lost 168 cops. Atlantic City, 60. Patterson, 125. Newark, 167. According to New Jersey governor Chris Christie, all these cuts are due to a clear culprit.
而且这种情况不仅仅发生在特伦顿，顺便说一下，特伦顿是新泽西州最后一个解雇警察的城市。卡姆登失去了168名警察。大西洋城60名。帕特森125名。纽瓦克167名。根据新泽西州州长克里斯·克里斯蒂（Chris Christie）的说法，所有这些削减都是由一个明确的罪魁祸首造成的。
Runaway salary costs. Three out of every four dollars that are spent now in any municipality or county is spent on labor costs. We can't afford it anymore.
失控的薪资成本。现在任何市政当局或县每花出的四美元中，就有三美元花在劳动力成本上。我们再也负担不起了。
Since he took office in 2010, Christie has wrestled New Jersey's finances into submission, largely by facing down the state's public sector unions. Cushy contracts for teachers and cops, millions paid out in unused sick days, Cadillac health plans, birthdays off with pay. Outrageous, he said. This is Christie at a VFW in Middletown, New Jersey last year, when a cop in the audience complained about having to pay more for his health care.
自2010年上任以来，克里斯蒂通过对抗州公共部门工会，迫使新泽西州的财政状况屈服。他称教师和警察的优厚合同、未休病假支付的数百万美元、顶级医疗计划、带薪生日假为无耻。这是去年克里斯蒂在新泽西州米德尔敦的一个退伍军人协会（VFW）讲话时的情景，当时观众席里的一名警察抱怨不得不为医疗保健支付更多费用。
My answer to you is, it stinks. But it's reality. And no one can be shielded from this reality anymore. Not police officers, not firefighters, not teachers. We have to reorient our expectations here. This is not 10 years ago. This is not a booming economy with 5% and 6% and 7% growth. We cannot afford this stuff anymore. We can't.
我给你的回答是，这很烂。但这就是现实。现在没有人能免受这种现实的影响。不是警察，不是消防员，也不是教师。我们必须在这里重新调整我们的期望。现在不是10年前了。现在不是经济繁荣、增长率为5%、6%或7%的时期。我们再也负担不起这些东西了。我们不能。
Hence the police layoffs. Thousands of them. As Christie calls it, the new reality. Trenton's new reality is that before Christie took office, the city received $36 million in what was called special aid to struggling municipalities. This year, Trenton's getting $22 million. And that aid has been re-branded. It's now called transitional aid. The idea being that cities eventually will wean themselves off it. Next year Trenton stands to get less.
因此出现了警察裁员。数以千计。正如克里斯蒂所说，这是“新现实”。特伦顿的新现实是，在克里斯蒂上任之前，该市获得了3600万美元的所谓“特殊援助”，用于帮助陷入困境的市政当局。今年，特伦顿获得了2200万美元。而且这项援助被重新命名了。现在它被称为“过渡性援助”。其理念是城市最终会戒掉它。明年特伦顿得到的会更少。
But a few days in Trenton makes you wonder if this new reality is tenable. Can the city even function like this?
但在特伦顿待上几天会让你怀疑这种新现实是否站得住脚。这座城市还能这样运作吗？
Listening audience, I think smaller government is a myth.
各位听众，我认为小政府是一个神话。
This is a guy named Michael Walker. He's not an elected official or think tank guy. He's not a businessman. He's a regular working-stiff taxpayer in the city of Trenton who's going out of his mind with frustration.
这是一个叫迈克尔·沃克（Michael Walker）的人。他不是民选官员，也不是智库成员。他不是商人。他是特伦顿市一名普通的工薪纳税人，正因沮丧而快要疯了。
And I think anyone who gets up there and tells you we're going to shrink the size of government, I think they're crazy. They're crazy. We have a hobbled police department that cannot keep up with the level of crime that is going on in our streets. We have a Department of Inspections that cannot keep up with the level of requests for plan reviews and for permits.
而且我认为任何站出来告诉你我们将缩小政府规模的人，我认为他们是疯了。他们疯了。我们有一个瘸腿的警察局，无法跟上我们街头上演的犯罪水平。我们有一个检查部门，无法跟上计划审查和许可证的请求水平。
We have a Public Works Department that cannot keep up with the filth that piles up in our city.
我们有一个公共工程部门，无法跟上在我们城市堆积的污秽。
He's become one of the most eloquent and loudest voices criticizing the state of affairs in Trenton, especially the police cuts. In the past few months he started a blog, published an editorial in the local paper, where he's also quoted pretty regularly.
他成为了批评特伦顿现状、特别是警察裁员的最雄辩、声音最大的人之一。过去几个月里，他开始写博客，在当地报纸上发表社论，他也经常在报纸上被引用。
I first saw him on YouTube back in September. That's when the city announced the police layoffs. And when Michael did something he's never done before. In a baggy black t-shirt, he went to City Hall for a council meeting, and delivered a speech that had people laughing and clapping. And he said something that's practically heresy in New Jersey, or really, anywhere else.
我第一次在YouTube上看到他是在9月。那是市政府宣布警察裁员的时候。迈克尔做了一件他从未做过的事。他穿着一件宽松的黑色T恤，去市政厅参加议会会议，发表了一场让人们又笑又鼓掌的演讲。他说出的话在新泽西州，或者实际上在任何其他地方，几乎都是异端。
And to be honest with you, I'd be willing to pay more taxes. And I know that this is not sustainable. I'm willing to pay more, because--
老实说，我愿意支付更多的税。我知道这是不可持续的。我愿意支付更多，因为——
I'd be willing to pay more taxes. In Trenton, to hire back 100 cops would cost about $5 million. So if your house is valued at, say, $100,000, it would cost you another $340 on your tax bill.
我愿意支付更多的税。在特伦顿，重新雇佣100名警察需要花费大约500万美元。因此，如果你的房子价值10万美元，你的税单上将增加340美元。
Happy to pay it.
很高兴支付。
That's Michael again. We talked in his car while we were driving to his house. Keep in mind, he's not a rich guy with money to spare. He made $34,000 last year.
那是迈克尔。我们在开车去他家的路上交谈。记住，他不是个有闲钱的富人。他去年赚了3.4万美元。
Really?
真的吗？
Happy to pay. $340 is nothing. Do you know what we're paying for basic cable? It's crazy. I mean, I'm not kidding you. Do you know what I'm paying for my cell phone bill every month? And do I really need to be getting minute by minute alerts through Facebook? This is a small price to pay to get more cops on.
很高兴支付。340美元算什么。你知道我们为基础有线电视支付了多少钱吗？这很疯狂。我是说，我不跟你开玩笑。你知道我每月为手机账单支付多少钱吗？我真的需要通过Facebook获取每分钟的提醒吗？这是一个增加警力的小代价。
Yes, taxes are too high. But taxes are too high for a variety of reasons. Because the money is not being used properly. But if the mayor said, look, this tax increase is designed to bring back all of the cops that we laid off, I'm all for it. In a heartbeat. Matter of fact, I'll send him a check for $350 now.
是的，税收太高了。但税收太高有很多原因。因为钱没有被正确使用。但如果市长说，看，这次加税是为了带回所有被我们解雇的警察，我全力支持。毫不犹豫。事实上，我现在就会给他寄一张350美元的支票。
Well, but nobody's suggesting this. Right?
嗯，但没人建议这么做。对吧？
No one. No one has the balls to suggest an additional tax increase to bring back the cops.
没有人。没有人有胆量提议增加税收来带回警察。
Is raising taxes an option to try to pay for those extra cops, to try to raise that $5 million?
加税是支付额外警力、筹集那500万美元的一个选择吗？
Absolutely not. Absolutely not.
绝对不是。绝对不是。
This is Marge Caldwell-Wilson again, the city council member.
这是玛吉·考德威尔-威尔逊，那位市议员。
The tax base in this city is so small that the burden on the taxpayers is huge. And we cannot, we cannot increase property taxes any more. Not only will we drive people out of the city and shrink the tax base even more, but it would drive businesses out of the city. And we are at the point right now where we're bleeding, and we can't afford to run anybody else out of town.
这个城市的税基太小，纳税人的负担非常沉重。我们不能，我们不能再增加房产税了。不仅会将人们赶出城市，进一步缩小税基，而且会将企业赶出城市。我们现在已经到了流血的地步，我们负担不起再把任何人赶出城了。
Trenton Mayor Tony Mack said much the same thing when I asked him.
特伦顿市长托尼·马克（Tony Mack）在被我问到时也说了同样的话。
No. No. I mean, I think people are taxed out. When I go out and I speak to residents, and a lot of them are on fixed incomes or senior citizens, and they're just plain and simple saying, "Mayor, I cannot afford another tax increase. I cannot afford to pay higher taxes." And I understand.
不。不。我是说，我认为人们的税负已经到了极限。当我出去和居民交谈时，他们中很多人是固定收入者或老年人，他们只是简单直接地说：“市长，我负担不起另一次加税。我负担不起支付更高的税。”我理解。
The city of Trenton, like all cities and towns in New Jersey, has only one tax it can levy, only one way to raise big money. Property taxes. There are no local sales or income taxes in New Jersey, just property taxes. The highest in the nation. The average New Jersey household spends nearly triple the national average on property taxes, which are regressive, by the way. They hit middle class and poor people hardest.
特伦顿市，像新泽西州的所有城市和城镇一样，只有一个可以征收的税，只有一种筹集大额资金的方法。房产税。新泽西州没有地方销售税或所得税，只有房产税。全美最高。新泽西州的普通家庭在房产税上的支出几乎是全国平均水平的三倍，顺便说一下，这些税是递减的。它们对中产阶级和穷人的打击最大。
In Trenton since 2005, the average tax bill has gone up by 42%. Obviously no one in Trenton wants to pay higher taxes. On the other hand, it's hard to imagine anything getting better with this amount of crime. Who's going to move here, invest here, open a business here? So I asked a couple dozen people, would they be willing to pay the extra, say, $340 in property taxes if it meant hiring 100 more cops? Their answers were all over the map. There were the absolute yeses.
在特伦顿，自2005年以来，平均税单上涨了42%。显然特伦顿没人想支付更高的税。另一方面，很难想象在如此严重的犯罪率下，情况会有所好转。谁会搬到这里，在这里投资，在这里开公司？所以我问了二十几个人，如果这意味着能多雇佣100名警察，他们是否愿意多支付比如说340美元的房产税？他们的回答各不相同。有绝对的“愿意”。
It's worth it. It's worth $300 and more. I mean, when you can live and just go to sleep at night, and be safe and comfortable.
这是值得的。值300美元甚至更多。我是说，当你能住在这里，晚上安心睡觉，感到安全和舒适时。
And yeses with conditions.
以及附带条件的肯定。
I would be willing to pay higher taxes for police officers who were willing to live in Trenton. Stop whining about the dangerous job they do. They knew it when they took the job. Yeah. Then I might consider higher taxes.
我愿意为那些愿意居住在特伦顿的警察支付更高的税。别再抱怨他们从事的危险工作了。他们在接受这份工作时就知道这一点。是的。那样我可能会考虑更高的税收。
Then there were the absolute nos. Would you be willing?
然后是绝对的“不愿意”。你愿意吗？
I wouldn't. No. No. Too high now.
我不愿意。不。不。现在已经太高了。
And I think these police officers, I think they're rude. They're ignorant. They're not friendly. Do you know what I mean?
而且我认为这些警察，我认为他们很粗鲁。他们很无知。他们不友好。你知道我的意思吗？
There were nos that went one step further.
还有更进一步的“不愿意”。
No. I feel that they should burn the city down and start over again. That's the way I feel.
不。我觉得他们应该把这座城市烧掉然后重新开始。我就是这么感觉的。
And there were the good natured nos, who were legitimately baffled.
还有那些好心肠的“不愿意”，他们确实感到困惑。
No. Because what are they doing with the taxes we pay now?
不。因为他们对我们现在缴纳的税做了什么？
That's John Mastoras, who owns a popular 24-hour diner in Trenton. The day after I left town, a guy with a gun tried to mug one of his bus boys right outside the front door. Back when he bought the business five years ago, his property taxes were around $5,700. And Trenton could afford the cops back then. Now he pays nearly $11,000, and suddenly Trenton can't afford them.
那是约翰·马斯托拉斯（John Mastoras），他在特伦顿拥有一家受欢迎的24小时营业的餐厅。我离开小镇的第二天，一个带枪的人试图在餐厅前门外抢劫他的一名洗碗工。五年前他买下这家店时，他的房产税大约是5700美元。那时特伦顿负担得起警察。现在他支付近1.1万美元，突然间特伦顿却负担不起了。
I mean, like I said, before, five years ago, used to pay almost half the amount of the tax we pay now, and they have those cops. Now we pay double and they don't have those cops. So what did they do with the money?
我是说，就像我说的，五年前，支付的税款几乎是我们现在支付的一半，而且他们有那些警察。现在我们付双倍的钱，他们却没有那些警察了。所以他们拿钱干什么去了？
That's really a good question.
这真是个好问题。
Which leads me to the most common answer I heard. Yes, I would pay more taxes, if I knew it would actually improve the city and make it safer. But I don't know that.
这让我听到了最常见的回答。是的，如果我知道它能真正改善城市并使其更安全，我会支付更多的税。但我不知道。
If I could pay to-- Yeah. I would pay higher taxes if I could have more police and I could have a better school system. But if I can't have either one of those things, then why should I continue to live here? And I have thought about moving. And that's my plan for 2013 is to sell my house.
如果我能支付……是的。如果我有更多的警察，拥有更好的学校系统，我愿意支付更高的税。但如果这两样我都得不到，那我为什么要继续住在这里？我想过搬家。我2013年的计划就是卖掉我的房子。
This is Talaya Stevens. She's a social worker for the state. Young, professional, a parent, a homeowner. The very taxpayer Trenton officials are worried they'll scare off. They're right to worry.
这是塔拉亚·史蒂文斯（Talaya Stevens）。她是州政府的一名社会工作者。年轻、专业、为人父母、房主。这正是特伦顿官员担心会吓跑的那种纳税人。他们的担心是对的。
If I paid another $1,000, I could live in Lawrenceville, I could live in Ewing, because their taxes are just as high. And I could get a better school district.
如果我多付1000美元，我可以住在劳伦斯维尔，我可以住在尤因，因为他们的税收也一样高。而且我能得到更好的学区。
These are towns right outside Trenton?
这些是特伦顿外面的城镇吗？
Right outside of Trenton.
就在特伦顿外面。
Now, people always complain about their government. Right? They always say they don't trust them to spend their hard earned tax money. That there's too much waste, too much incompetence. But in this case, they're justified. One state official characterized Trenton as the most mismanaged municipality in the entire state. And not by a little. By a lot.
现在，人们总是抱怨他们的政府。对吧？他们总是说他们不信任政府去花他们辛辛苦苦赚来的纳税钱。说有太多的浪费，太多的无能。但在这种情况下，他们是有道理的。一位州官员将特伦顿描述为整个州管理最混乱的城市。不是一点点。而是非常乱。
The dysfunction in Trenton, a mountain of blame for it, is laid on Mayor Tony Mack. Everyone I talked to said the mayor was either not up to the job, or making things worse. That he fired good people and hired terrible ones. His deputy mayor and chief of staff was arrested trying to buy heroin after just seven weeks on the job.
特伦顿的功能失调，大部分归咎于市长托尼·马克。我交谈过的每个人都说市长要么不能胜任这份工作，要么让事情变得更糟。说他解雇了优秀的人，雇佣了糟糕的人。他的副市长和幕僚长在入职仅七周后就因试图购买海洛因而被捕。
Mack's half brother, who worked at the water plant, was caught stealing city materials. He's about to go to jail. His housing director quit after it came out that he had a theft conviction. The list goes on. The list really does go on.
在水处理厂工作的马克的同母异父兄弟，因偷窃城市物资被抓。他即将入狱。他的住房局局长在被揭发有盗窃前科后辞职。名单还在继续。名单确实还在继续。
This is the worst I've seen the city, ever. Ever. Ever. The worst.
这是我见过的这座城市最糟糕的情况，从来没有过。从来没有。最糟糕的。
This is Tracey Syphax, effects of a successful real estate developer. And he'd happily pay more property taxes to hire more cops. But not while this mayor's in charge.
这是特雷西·赛法克斯（Tracey Syphax），一位成功的房地产开发商。他很乐意多付房产税来雇佣更多的警察。但不是在这个市长执政期间。
I hear all the time people saying, 'Well, the governor should give this mayor the money he needs." Who would do that, when you have a mayor that has had four police directors in two years? Eight business administrators in two years. Two law directors in two years. I mean, who would give money to that? That's like me giving money to my five-year-old granddaughter, and expecting her to do the right thing with it.
我经常听到人们说，“嗯，州长应该给市长他需要的钱。”谁会这样做，当你的市长在两年内换了四任警察局长？两年内换了八任行政主管。两年内换了两个法律主任。我是说，谁会把钱给那样的人？那就像是我把钱给我的五岁孙女，指望她用钱做正确的事一样。
So that's it. Trenton isn't going to get more money from taxpayers. It's not going to get more money from the state. Crime is rising, and now there's talk of closing fire stations. And people in Trenton have no confidence their government can stop this downward spiral. And you can understand why.
所以就是这样。特伦顿不会从纳税人那里得到更多钱。它不会从州政府得到更多钱。犯罪率在上升，现在还有关闭消防站的说法。特伦顿的人民对他们的政府能否阻止这种螺旋式下降毫无信心。你可以理解为什么。
So they lock their doors, pull the shades, maybe turn on cable. Which, for say, $159 a month, would pay for about 600 more cops in Trenton.
所以他们锁好门，拉上窗帘，也许打开有线电视。顺便说一下，每月159美元，这足够支付特伦顿大约600名额外的警察。
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our show.
莎拉·科尼格是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Two, Dream Come True. So we now live in a world where the idea of raising taxes simply will not be considered in most American communities, even in places where taxes are much lower than they are in New Jersey. And the one person who arguably did the most to get us here, who created the political reality that you and I and President Obama are all living in today, is Grover Norquist.
第二幕，梦想成真。我们现在生活在一个大多数美国社区根本不考虑加税想法的世界里，即使是在税收比新泽西州低得多的地方。而那个可以说在促成这一切方面做得最多的人，创造了你、我和奥巴马总统今天都生活在其中的政治现实的人，是格罗弗·诺奎斯特（Grover Norquist）。
Each Wednesday, he holds a meeting where dozens of conservative political groups come together and share their plans. He created his own group, Americans for Tax Reform, in 1985. A year later came his biggest and most successful invention. He started asking every Republican running for national and statewide office to sign a pledge never to increase taxes.
每周三，他都会举行会议，数十个保守派政治团体聚集在一起分享他们的计划。他在1985年创立了自己的组织“美国人争取税制改革”（Americans for Tax Reform）。一年后，他推出了规模最大、最成功的发明。他开始要求每一位竞选全国和全州职位的共和党人签署一项承诺，绝不增加税收。
At this point it's just what you do as a Republican candidate. Such a given that even a fake candidate like Stephen Colbert, four years ago, when he decided to run for president, he started by having Norquist on his show and signing the pledge.
在这一点上，这只是你作为共和党候选人必须做的事情。这是一个既定的事实，甚至像斯蒂芬·科尔伯特（Stephen Colbert）这样的假候选人，四年前，当他决定竞选总统时，他首先就是在节目中请诺奎斯特上台并签署了这项承诺。
We would love to have your support.
我们很乐意得到您的支持。
Here we go. "I, Stephen Colbert, pledge to the taxpayers of the United States of America that I will, one, oppose any and all efforts to increase the marginal income tax rates for individuals and or businesses, and two, oppose any net reduction or elimination of deductions and credits unless matched dollar for dollar by further reducing tax rates." I have no problem signing that, sir, because I don't know what any of that means. Thank you so much, Grover Norquist.
开始了。“我，斯蒂芬·科尔伯特，向美利坚合众国的纳税人承诺，我将：第一，反对任何及所有增加个人和/或企业边际所得税率的努力；第二，反对任何扣除额和抵免额的净减少或取消，除非通过进一步降低税率实现等额抵扣。”我签署这个没有任何问题，先生，因为我不知道那意味着什么。非常感谢你，格罗弗·诺奎斯特。
Holding the line on taxes, preventing lawmakers from approving new taxes, Grover Norquist told me, is a way to advance his bigger goal, to reduce the size of government.
格罗弗·诺奎斯特告诉我，控制税收，阻止立法者批准新的税收，是一种推进他更大的目标的方式，即缩小政府规模。
As long as tax increases are even part of the national conversation or state conversation or city conversation, you never have a conversation about reforming government. It's when you say taxes will not be raised that you then look around and go, do we have to do everything we've been doing? Do we have to do it the way we've been doing it?
只要增加税收还在全国讨论、州讨论或城市讨论中，你就永远不会讨论政府改革。当你宣布税收不会增加时，你才会环顾四周并问，我们是否必须做我们一直在做的所有事情？我们是否必须以我们一直以来的方式去做？
This, of course, is exactly what lawmakers at the federal, state and local level have been doing for most of this past year. They are living out the scenario that Grover Norquist envisioned years ago, to squeeze the size of government.
当然，这正是联邦、州和地方层面的立法者过去这一年来大部分时间里一直在做的事情。他们正在实现格罗弗·诺奎斯特多年前设想的情景，即缩减政府规模。
The most famous thing Norquist ever said was that he wanted the federal government so small that you could drown it in a bathtub. But at some point in the 1990s, he named a more achievable goal-- half. He wanted the federal government to be half the size it was. And over the course of the Clinton administration, he says, with Republicans in the house, we seemed to be on our way. The federal government shrank significantly.
诺奎斯特说过的最著名的话是他希望联邦政府小到可以把它淹死在浴缸里。但在20世纪90年代的某个时候，他提出了一个更容易实现的目标——减半。他希望联邦政府的规模减小到原来的一半。他说，在克林顿执政期间，随着共和党控制众议院，我们似乎正在朝着这个方向努力。联邦政府显著缩小了。
You've said in the past that your goal is to cut the federal government by half. Is that still your goal?
你过去曾说过你的目标是将联邦政府规模减少一半。那还是你的目标吗？
Sure. Let's make a list of things that the government's doing today that make the world a worse off place, and stop those, for starters.
当然。让我们先列出政府今天所做的一些让世界变得更糟糕的事情，并停止这些。
And then what would that be? Like, what would you do away with? Like would you get rid of all entitlements? What would you do? What does it mean?
那会是什么？例如，你会废除什么？你会摆脱所有的权利福利吗？你会怎么做？那意味着什么？
I'm in favor of reforming government to become smaller rather than some sort of procrustean bed where you chop off people's toes to make people fit in the bed. And frankly, I think if you talk about reforming government, Utah just passed a law. And the law says, all new hires, state and local government in Utah, will have a defined contribution pension, a 401(k). Here's your pay, here's 10% of your pay to go into a 401(k). 12% if you're a policeman or fireman and are expected to retire earlier.
我赞成改革政府以变小，而不是某种普罗克鲁斯提斯之床（Procrustean bed，指削足适履），把人的脚趾砍掉来让人们适应床铺。老实说，如果你谈论改革政府，犹他州刚刚通过了一项法律。法律规定，犹他州所有新聘用的州和地方政府人员，都将拥有确定缴费型养老金，即401(k)。这是你的工资，工资的10%进入401(k)。如果你是警察或消防员，预计会提前退休，则为12%。
Are you following this? In other words, instead of a state-run pension plan, the state puts 10% to 12% of your salary into a personal retirement account for you. An account that's yours. That you control. A 401(k) like lots of people have already.
你听懂了吗？换句话说，州政府不再使用州营养老金计划，而是将你工资的10%到12%存入你的个人退休账户。一个属于你的账户。由你控制。一个像许多人已经拥有的那样的401(k)。
And there's no Ponzi scheme. Almost all of the state and local pensions are out of whack. The money's not there to pay people as it was promised. If you moved all government-run pensions to defined contribution, you would dramatically reduce the unfunded liabilities of state and local government, which are eating up more and more of state and local budgets.
而且没有庞氏骗局。几乎所有的州和地方养老金都乱套了。没有钱支付承诺给人们的钱。如果你将所有政府经营的养老金改为确定缴费型，你将大幅减少州和地方政府的无资金负债，这些负债正吞噬越来越多的州和地方预算。
OK, I don't know if you noticed what he just did there. When I asked him what he would get rid of to shrink the government to half of its size, he launched into describing this very sensible sounding reform that's going on in Utah. He did this over and over. I asked him four times. Spent 17 minutes of our 45 minute interview trying to get him to give me a list of cuts which he never gave me.
好吧，我不知道你是否注意到了他刚才做了什么。当我问他他会废除什么来把政府规模缩减到一半时，他开始描述这个正在犹他州进行、听起来非常合理的改革。他一遍又一遍地这样做。我问了他四次。在我们45分钟的采访中，花了17分钟试图让他给我一份削减清单，但他从未给过我。
Can I ask you, do you feel hesitant to get into sketching out a picture of, like, here's what the government looks like when it's radically smaller? Because it alarms people, like, when you sketch that out. And it's better to talk about, here are some concrete things we can do that everyone would agree on.
我可以问一下吗，你是否感到犹豫，不敢去描绘一个当政府规模彻底缩小后是什么样子的画面？因为当你会描绘那个时，人们会感到恐慌。谈论一些每个人都能同意的具体事情会更好。
Well, I think you want to talk about things one at a time so that it's clear. We're not talking about doing some sort of mad experiment. We're talking about taking a look at things that have worked in other states and giving people options.
嗯，我想你想一次谈论一件事情，这样才清楚。我们不是在谈论进行某种疯狂的实验。我们是在谈论看看其他州行之有效的事情并给人们选择。
Later I talked to another small government guy, Len Gilroy, the head of government reform at the Reason Foundation. And he said to me that this isn't evasiveness. He said that, as a practical matter, voters do not want to take a big axe to social security or Medicare or other popular programs. So why even speculate about a world where that could happen?
后来我与另一位小政府人士伦·吉尔罗伊（Len Gilroy）交谈，他是“理性基金会”（Reason Foundation）政府改革部门的负责人。他对我表示，这不是回避。他说，从实际情况来看，选民不想对社会保障、医疗保险或其他受欢迎的项目动大斧头。那么为什么还要推测一个这种情况可能发生的世界呢？
He said guys like him and Norquist don't have a secret list of government budget cuts in their back pocket. What they have is a list of reforms, like this law in Utah that would make government cheaper. Some of that stuff, like the Utah law, seems market tested to sound reasonable to most people. Other stuff, like breaking the backs of public sector unions, which Grover Norquist can go on and on about, is as divisive as it gets.
他说像他和诺奎斯特这样的人，口袋里并没有政府预算削减的秘密清单。他们有一份清单，列出的是像犹他州那样的法律，可以让政府成本更低。其中一些东西，比如犹他州的法律，看起来经过市场检验，听起来对大多数人是合理的。而其他东西，比如打破公共部门工会的后盾——这是格罗弗·诺奎斯特可以滔滔不绝谈论的——却是极具争议的。
The best way to reform the cost of government is what Scott Walker did in Wisconsin, which was to undo tenure.
改革政府成本的最好方法是像斯科特·沃克（Scott Walker）在威斯康星州所做的那样，即取消终身任期。
Here's something that might surprise you. Our nation's current mania for cutting the size of government, keeping taxes low, is coming at a moment when our tax rates are, in fact, at one of the lowest levels in the last 70 years. The top personal income tax bracket paid over 80% of its income in the 1950s and '60s to the government, 70% when Ronald Reagan took office, 39% at the end of the Clinton years. Now it is 35%, with lower tax brackets paying less, of course.
这里有一件事可能会让你感到惊讶。我们国家目前对于削减政府规模、保持低税率的狂热，正值我们的税率实际上处于过去70年最低水平之一的时刻。最高个人所得税等级在50和60年代支付了超过80%的收入给政府，罗纳德·里根上任时为70%，克林顿任期结束时为39%。现在是35%，当然低税率等级支付得更少。
Our taxes make up a smaller portion of the gross domestic product than taxes in most industrialized countries. When you look at it this way, it can seem very strange that this is a time when politicians are so unwilling to raise taxes, with all kinds of unintended consequences to that everywhere.
我们的税收占国内生产总值（GDP）的比例比大多数工业化国家都要低。当你从这个角度看时，政客们如此不愿意加税，到处产生各种意想不到的后果，这看起来非常奇怪。
Can I ask you to talk about just the messiness of what's happening around the country as people are cutting budgets. So for example, in New Jersey, we have these cities, Camden, Trenton, Newark, where in order to make their budgets work now without raising taxes, they're cutting huge percentages of the police forces. And crime is going up.
你能谈谈全国各地在削减预算时出现的混乱情况吗？例如，在新泽西州，我们有卡姆登、特伦顿、纽瓦克这些城市，为了在不加税的情况下让预算运转，他们正在大幅裁减警察人数。犯罪率在上升。
When you see that, when you hear about that, do you just feel like, OK, well, this is just the clumsy first steps of something? What is your take on that?
当你看到这一点，当你听到这个消息时，你是否觉得，好吧，这只是某种笨拙的初步步骤？你的看法是什么？
When you try and cut the size of government without reforming it, you have serious challenges. In New Jersey, the examples you used, organized labor in the public sector is very strong. And so you can't come in and say, could we work different hours or different days? Or how about that we lay off the 10% incompetent guys on the police force? No, you lay off the most recently hired guys who may be the most competent.
当你试图在不改革的情况下缩减政府规模时，你会面临严峻的挑战。在新泽西州，在你使用的例子中，公共部门的组织劳工非常强大。所以你不能进来说，我们能不能换个工时或日子？或者裁掉警察部队中10%不称职的人怎么样？不，你裁掉的是最近雇佣的、可能是最有能力的人。
In fact, this is exactly what happened in Trenton. They fired all the younger cops and filled their slots by demoting 2/3 of their supervisors. It was pretty ham-fisted.
事实上，这正是特伦顿发生的事情。他们解雇了所有年轻的警察，通过降职三分之二的监督人员来填补空缺。这真是相当笨拙。
Here's just how ambitious Norquist is. Back in the 1990s, with Bill Clinton in the White House and Republicans in the House of Representatives, the goal that Norquist and his allies set for themselves could not have been bigger. To completely realign the politics of the United States. To use their skills with talking points and issues and candidates to push the entire country towards a solid majority that would vote for smaller government and lower taxes.
这就是诺奎斯特的雄心壮志。回到90年代，比尔·克林顿在白宫，共和党在众议院，诺奎斯特和他的盟友们为自己设定的目标极其宏大。彻底重塑美国的政治。利用他们在谈话要点、议题和候选人方面的技巧，推动整个国家走向一个坚定的多数派，投票支持小政府和低税收。
A great article about Norquist in The New Yorker in 2005 ends with Norquist running into somebody who he knows on the street, who asks him, "How's it going?" Norquist replies-- and this does not seem like a brag but just a statement of fact the way he says it-- "We're winning." When I interviewed him at his office two weeks ago, he said this past year, he has definitely been feeling that same way. His side is winning.
《纽约客》2005年关于诺奎斯特的一篇伟大的文章结尾是诺奎斯特在街上遇到一个熟人，对方问他：“进展如何？”诺奎斯特回答道——他说这话时似乎不是吹嘘，只是陈述事实——“我们赢了。”两周前我在他的办公室采访他时，他说过去这一年，他绝对有同样的感觉。他这一方赢了。
After all, he said, 2011 was a year where you would normally see a tax increase. The government needs money because in a recession it is bringing in way less revenue than usual. There's a massive shortfall. And for two years, to help the States cope with the shortfall, President Obama's stimulus package sent billions to all the states. But that just ended.
毕竟，他说，2011年本来应该是一个增加税收的年份。政府需要钱，因为在经济衰退中，它获得的收入比通常少得多。出现了巨大的缺口。两年来，为了帮助各州应对缺口，奥巴马总统的刺激计划向各州拨付了数十亿美元。但那刚刚结束。
So you're supposed to have 50 states going we must raise taxes to replace the stimulus spending. And at the federal level, hey, let's raise taxes. And both at the national level and at the state level, 45 states said no to tax increases and only five raised taxes. So if it was just Washington, you'd go, OK, the guys in Washington DC traumatized by Obama's spending. But when 50 states are having the same fight and in 45 of them you don't raise taxes and you do cut spending, that's very positive.
所以你应该会有50个州说我们必须加税来代替刺激支出。而在联邦层面，嘿，让我们加税。无论是在国家层面还是州层面，45个州对加税说了不，只有5个州加了税。所以如果只是华盛顿，你会说，好吧，华盛顿特区的人被奥巴马的支出吓坏了。但当50个州都在进行同样的争论，而在其中45个州你不加税且确实削减了支出，那是非常积极的。
But it's not just about taxes. For Norquist and his allies who want to see a radically smaller government, these past three years have been especially promising. He says he is seeing a shift in the Republican Party that goes beyond taxes.
但不仅仅是关于税收。对于诺奎斯特和他那些希望看到彻底缩减政府的盟友来说，过去三年尤其令人充满希望。他说他在共和党内看到了一个超越税收的变化。
Up until the Tea Party movement, there was too much of a willingness of Republicans to allow spending to drift upwards. That was the Bush story. Bush got the message, don't raise taxes. He didn't get the message about spending less and reducing total government spending from where it was. So the Bush years were lost years for limited government.
在茶党运动之前，共和党人对允许支出向上漂移太过于意愿了。那是布什的故事。布什收到了信息，不要加税。他没有收到关于少花钱和减少政府总支出的信息。所以布什时代是有限政府失去的岁月。
It took the shock of Obama's massive spending increase to scare voters enough to create the Tea Party movement, who then entered the modern Republican Party and revigorate it. And saying to the modern Republican Party, stop spending so much. Big, big change in the modern Republican Party. That's one of the things that gives me real hope. From Christie's New Jersey to Scott's Florida to Kasich's Ohio, to Boehner and Mitch McConnell in Washington.
这花费了奥巴马大规模增加支出的冲击来吓唬选民，足以建立茶党运动，他们随后进入现代共和党并使其恢复活力。并对现代共和党说，停止花这么多钱。现代共和党发生了巨大的变化。这是让我真正充满希望的事情之一。从克里斯蒂的新泽西到斯科特的佛罗里达，到卡西奇的俄亥俄，再到华盛顿的博纳（Boehner）和米奇·麦康奈尔（Mitch McConnell）。
There's nothing you can't do in the United States over a 25-year period. With enough time-- that's Archimedes' lever, is time-- you can do a lot of stuff over time.
在美国，没有什么是你在25年里做不到的。有足够的时间——那是阿基米德的杠杆，是时间——随着时间的推移，你可以做很多事情。
A generation, Norquist says. That's his time frame. Give him 25 years to radically reduce the size of government. After all, he's already on his way. He's winning.
一代人，诺奎斯特说。那是他的时间框架。给他25年来彻底减少政府规模。毕竟，他已经在路上了。他赢了。
Coming up, a city employee rises from the ashes like a phoenix. That's in a minute, from subscriber Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一名市政府雇员像凤凰一样从灰烬中崛起。那将在稍后播出，来自订阅者公共广播和国际公共广播，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, what kind of country do we want? At this moment when so much of our politics seems to be obsessed with how to cut back on government, we have stories of people choosing whether they want more government or less, more taxes or fewer, we have arrived at Act Three of our show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，我们想要什么样的国家？在这样一个时刻，我们的政治似乎如此痴迷于如何削减政府开支，我们有一些人们选择他们想要更多政府还是更少、更多税收还是更少的个人故事，我们已经进入了我们节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Do You Want a Wake Up Call? In Colorado Springs, Colorado, when they had budget troubles a couple years ago, the city did something that made them momentarily famous around the country. They turned off a third of their street lights to save electricity costs. Since then, other cities have followed their lead. But when this first happened in Colorado Springs, people like Jamie Lindsay didn't know what was going on.
第三幕，你想要一个警钟吗？在科罗拉多州的科罗拉多斯普林斯，几年前当他们遇到预算困难时，该市做了一件让他们在全国范围内短暂成名的事情。他们关闭了三分之一的街道照明以节省电力成本。从那以后，其他城市也效仿了他们的做法。但当这件事第一次发生在科罗拉多斯普林斯时，像杰米·林赛（Jamie Lindsay）这样的人根本不知道发生了什么。
We were just outside playing basketball, and then, all of a sudden, we were like, hey, why isn't the street light on? And the girls were like, what's going on with the street light?
我们在外面打篮球，然后，突然，我们就像，嘿，为什么路灯不亮？女孩们就问，路灯怎么了？
Colorado Springs didn't stop at cutting streetlights. Public restrooms were locked, bus service slashed. Those nice little flower beds in the median strips of the streets downtown, wilted, dead. The amazing thing about Colorado Springs, though, was what it decided to do about this mess. They did something different from any other city.
科罗拉多斯普林斯并没有止步于削减路灯。公共厕所被锁住，公交服务被削减。市中心街道中间那些漂亮的小花坛，枯萎、死亡。然而，科罗拉多斯普林斯令人惊奇的是，它决定如何处理这堆烂摊子。他们做了一件与任何其他城市不同的事情。
They decided to live the conservative dream, keep a smaller government, give the free market a chance to handle some of these city services in some very unusual ways. Robert Smith travelled to Colorado Springs and reports on the results of the experiment.
他们决定过一种保守派的梦想，保持一个小政府，让自由市场有机会以一些非常不寻常的方式处理这些城市服务。罗伯特·史密斯（Robert Smith）前往科罗拉多斯普林斯并报告了实验结果。
The residents of Colorado Springs should've seen it coming. When the recession hit, the city gave everyone fair warning. Here are the things we have to cut-- police, fire, those beautiful parks all over Colorado Springs. All of this could be gone, the city said, if you don't vote to raise your taxes.
科罗拉多斯普林斯的居民应该预见到这一点。当经济衰退来袭时，市政府给了每个人公平的警告。这是我们必须削减的东西——警察、消防、科罗拉多斯普林斯到处那些美丽的公园。这一切都可能消失，市政府说，如果你不投票支持加税的话。
I don't think I took it very seriously.
我不认为我太认真对待了。
This is Bo Sharifi. He and his wife Sara and their two kids live up in the foothills of Colorado Springs.
这是波·沙里菲（Bo Sharifi）。他和妻子萨拉以及两个孩子住在科罗拉多斯普林斯的山脚下。
As soon as I hear government, oh, we need more money, I don't know. I guess I kind of automatically assume, yeah, there's probably some other things you could probably cut before firemen, policemen, city lights, and that sort of thing.
只要我听到政府说，噢，我们需要更多的钱，我不知道。我想我会自动假设，是的，在你削减消防员、警察、城市照明和这类事情之前，可能还有其他一些东西你可以削减。
So when his street light went dark, he didn't put two and two together.
所以当他的路灯熄灭时，他并没有把两件事联系起来。
Being the Good Samaritan, I called the city. And I was like, "Hey, you need to come out and fix this light." They're like, "Oh, yeah. You remember that tax increase you didn't vote for?" I was like, "Uh, maybe."
作为好撒玛利亚人，我给市政府打了电话。我就说，“嘿，你需要出来修好这盏灯。”他们说，“噢，是的。你还记得你没有投票支持的加税吗？”我就说，“嗯，也许。”
The guy on the phone explained to Bo how life was going to be in Colorado Springs from now on. If you want your street light, he said, you have to pay for it. For $125, the city would send someone to Bo's street and turn back on the electricity. $125. You could pay by credit card. For Bo and his wife Sarah, it was hard to believe at first. It seemed like some kind of scam, some kind of payback from the city.
电话那头的人向波解释了从今以后科罗拉多斯普林斯的生活会是什么样子。如果你想要你的路灯，他说，你必须付费。花125美元，市政府会派人到波的街道上，重新接通电力。125美元。你可以用信用卡支付。对于波和他的妻子萨拉来说，起初很难相信。这看起来像某种骗局，像某种市政府的报复。
Because it felt like, in a way, by shoveling out $100 to turn on a street light that we kind of felt was supposed to be on anyway, that it was giving them what they wanted.
因为感觉就像，在某种程度上，通过掏出100美元来打开一盏我们觉得本来就应该亮着的路灯，这是在给他们想要的东西。
Giving who what they wanted?
给谁他们想要的东西？
The city. I think people were just kind of ticked.
市政府。我想人们只是有点被惹毛了。
The Sharifis and their neighbors said fine. We will pay for lights ourselves. And hundreds of other people around the city did the exact same thing. Colorado Springs became an unusual place, a city where the people who could afford streetlights paid for them, a la carte. Others lived in the dark. It was like the capital of some very snowy, unusually affluent third world country.
沙里菲一家和他们的邻居们说行。我们会自己付路灯钱。城市里的数百人做了完全一样的事情。科罗拉多斯普林斯变成了一个不寻常的地方，一个能够负担得起路灯的人单点支付费用的城市。其他人生活在黑暗中。就像某个多雪、异常富裕的第三世界国家的首都。
You could see it driving around. Colorado Springs was stepping away from one of the things that we take for granted in most American cities, that we're all in it together. At least when it comes to basic services.
你可以开车绕着看。科罗拉多斯普林斯正在远离我们在大多数美国城市中视为理所当然的一件事，那就是我们都在同一条船上。至少当谈到基本服务时。
And it wasn't just streetlights. Alison Foster lives next door to a park. No more trash cans, no more watering. Alison asked her neighbors for donations. And if you thought $125 for streetlights was expensive, get this. Adopting a city park, $2,500.
而且不仅仅是路灯。艾莉森·福斯特（Alison Foster）住在公园隔壁。没有垃圾桶，没有浇水。艾莉森向她的邻居募捐。如果你认为路灯的125美元很贵，听这个。领养一个城市公园，2500美元。
They put the trash cans back after we sent in our money.
在我们寄出钱后，他们把垃圾桶放回去了。
To some people, that's going to sound like an extortion racket.
对某些人来说，这听起来像是一个敲诈勒索。
Yeah, I know, I know. It did after I just said that.
是的，我知道，我知道。在我刚才说那话之后确实是。
The money, by the way, was for trash cans and sprinklers. But the neighbors had to collect and haul the garbage themselves.
顺便说一句，这些钱是用于垃圾桶和喷头的。但邻居们必须自己收集和清运垃圾。
In the end, I think a lot of us felt like, OK, how long are we going to have to do this? And when is the city going to pick this up again?
最后，我想我们很多人觉得，好吧，我们要这样干多久？市政府什么时候会再接手？
It's no accident that Colorado Springs is the place where all this happened. Colorado Springs is not just conservative, it is famous for being conservative. It's the home of Focus on the Family, evangelical churches like the New Life Church, four military bases, Air Force Academy. It is in the most right-leaning congressional district in all of Colorado. Add to the mix outdoorsy types, mountain bikers, ex-hippies, and you get this kind of pioneer leave me alone vibe around here.
科罗拉多斯普林斯发生这一切并非偶然。科罗拉多斯普林斯不仅是保守的，它以保守而闻名。它是“聚焦家庭”（Focus on the Family）、像新生活教会（New Life Church）这样的福音派教堂、四个军事基地、空军学院的所在地。它是科罗拉多州所有右翼倾向最明显的国会选区。再加上喜欢户外活动的人、山地自行车手、前嬉皮士，你就会得到那种拓荒者“别管我”的氛围。
The citizens of Colorado Springs didn't just believe in limited government, they made it law. 20 years ago they passed the Taxpayer Bill of Rights. TABOR, everyone calls it. And TABOR-- you may have heard of this because other states have put it on the ballot. But it started right here in Colorado Springs. Under TABOR, if you want to raise or impose any tax at all, you have to get the voters to approve it first.
科罗拉多斯普林斯的公民不仅相信小政府，他们还将其定为法律。20年前，他们通过了《纳税人权利法案》。每个人都称之为TABOR。而且TABOR——你可能听说过这个，因为其他州也把它放到了投票议程上。但它就始于科罗拉多斯普林斯。根据TABOR，如果你想增加或征收任何税，你必须先让选民批准。
Our voters very rarely will support a tax increase.
我们的选民很少会支持加税。
This is Colorado Springs City Councilwoman Jan Martin, one of the people who deals with TABOR day in and day out. TABOR is like a set of handcuffs for city government. It limits how much you can grow your budget, makes it hard to shift money from one thing to another. The city survives mostly on sales tax, which is great when the town is filled with tourists, right? All those hikers and mountain bikers buying energy bars.
这是科罗拉多斯普林斯市议员简·马丁（Jan Martin），每天处理TABOR的人之一。TABOR就像是城市政府的手铐。它限制了你的预算增长幅度，使你难以把钱从一件事情转到另一件事情。该市主要依靠销售税生存，当城镇里挤满了游客时这很棒，对吧？所有那些买能量棒的徒步旅行者和山地自行车手。
But when a recession comes along, living off sales tax is a disaster.
但当经济衰退来袭时，依靠销售税生存就是一场灾难。
What we experienced when the downturn occurred is, immediately, people stopped buying, which meant our dollars dropped faster than most communities. And we crashed and burned almost simultaneously with the economic downturn.
当经济下滑发生时，我们经历的是，人们立即停止购买，这意味着我们的美元下降速度比大多数社区快。我们几乎与经济下滑同时崩溃。
In 2009, tens of millions of dollars the city was counting on didn't materialize. Jan believed TABOR only gave her one choice. She had to ask voters for the tax increase you heard about. And this wasn't easy for Jan. She's a Republican. She owns her own business. She has an MBA in finance. But she thought, I just need to be straight with voters about the situation we're in.
2009年，该市指望的数千万美元没有出现。简相信TABOR只给她一个选择。她必须请求选民批准你听说的那次加税。这对简来说并不容易。她是共和党人。她经营自己的企业。她拥有金融MBA学位。但她想，我只需要对选民坦诚我们所处的境地。
She said, look., the city needs to raise $28 million. That means the average homeowner would have to kick in about $200 a year.
她说，看，市政府需要筹集2800万美元。这意味着普通房主每年需要出大约200美元。
To go before the voters in the middle of an economic downturn, I will admit, it was pretty gutsy. But I really felt as an elected official I owed it to the general public to give them an option before the cuts were made.
在经济衰退期间去选民面前，我承认，这相当有胆量。但我真的觉得作为民选官员，我有责任给公众提供一个选项，在削减之前。
It wasn't even close. The voters in Colorado Springs said no way. Nearly 2/3 of them voted against the tax.
投票结果甚至并不接近。科罗拉多斯普林斯的选民说了没门。近三分之二的人投票反对这项税收。
The next morning when I got up, my email box was filled with the most vile email messages I personally have ever received after five years on city council. Accusing me of destroying our city, and how dare I bring this forward at a time like this. And how crazy I was and how stupid I was. That is the part that stunned me.
第二天早上当我起床时，我的电子邮箱里塞满了我在市议会工作五年以来个人收到的最恶毒的电子邮件。指责我正在摧毁我们的城市，在这样的时刻怎么敢提出这个建议。说我有多疯狂，我有多愚蠢。那部分让我震惊。
And that's how the Colorado Springs experiment began. With government and its citizens bickering back and forth, mean, resentful. And wondering if someone could come up with a better way.
而这就是科罗拉多斯普林斯实验开始的方式。政府和公民之间吵来吵去，刻薄、怨恨。并想知道是否有人能想出更好的方法。
Now everything might have stayed like this if not for one man, up on a hillside above Colorado Springs watching this whole drama. He's a private guy, usually keeps to himself and his own business. But he was about to write a manifesto. A blueprint for how the city could solve all of its problems.
现在一切可能就维持这样了，如果不是因为一个人，在科罗拉多斯普林斯上方的一处山坡上看着整出戏。他是个私下里的人，通常保持沉默，只专注于自己的生意。但他准备写一份宣言。一份关于城市如何解决所有问题的蓝图。
I'm Steve Bartolin, and I'm the president and CEO of the Broadmoor Hotel in Colorado Springs, Colorado.
我是史蒂夫·巴托林（Steve Bartolin），我是科罗拉多州科罗拉多斯普林斯的布罗德莫酒店（Broadmoor Hotel）的总裁兼首席执行官。
Now when I first heard about Steve Bartolin, I thought, why would the city council, or anyone really, listen to a guy who runs a hotel? Well, the answer is, this isn't just any hotel.
现在当我第一次听说史蒂夫·巴托林时，我想，为什么市议会，或者真的有任何人，会听一个经营酒店的人的话？嗯，答案是，这不仅仅是任何酒店。
Welcome to the Broadmoor. The place that you may have thought existed only in your grandest dreams and fondest imagination.
欢迎来到布罗德莫。这个你可能认为只存在于你最宏伟的梦想和最美好的想象中的地方。
That's the promotional video. But my producer Brian Reed and I had to see this place for ourselves.
那是宣传片。但我的制片人布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）和我必须亲眼看看这个地方。
Welcome to the Broadmoor, Mr. Smith and Mr. Reed.
欢迎来到布罗德莫，史密斯先生和里德先生。
One of the bellmen, Dan Saluski, walked us around the grounds. Though, really, it's more like a small city.
行李员之一，丹·萨卢斯基（Dan Saluski），带我们参观了场地。虽然，实际上，它更像是一个小城市。
You can do about anything you want here. 3,000 acre property, three championship golf courses.
你可以在这里做任何你想做的事。3000英亩的房产，三个锦标赛高尔夫球场。
13 restaurants, 24 stores, a transit system.
13家餐厅，24家商店，一个交通系统。
Our shuttles will take you anywhere on the property including the zoo.
我们的班车会带你去房产内的任何地方，包括动物园。
Plus the whole place has this fragrance that hangs in the air. They pump it in. It's like lemon sage something. And when I asked the front desk about it, I was told the perfume has a name. The smell of the Broadmoor, and I'm not making this up, is called Optimism.
加上整个地方空气中弥漫着一种香味。他们抽进去的。就像柠檬鼠尾草之类的。当我问前台时，我被告知这种香水有个名字。布罗德莫的味道，我没有编造，叫做“乐观”。
I've had a lady, when I opened up the door, she cried. It just was absolutely everything that she thought it was going to be, staying at the Broadmoor.
我有个女士，当我打开门时，她哭了。这绝对就是她认为待在布罗德莫会是的样子，一切都完全一样。
So, yeah. I finally understood. When the CEO of Shangri-La writes a manifesto, people pay attention. Back in the city's dark days, as the parks were turning brown, the Broadmoor remained green and lush. And Steve Bartolin was up here watching what the Colorado Springs city council was doing. And he was not happy. The Broadmoor is one of the city's biggest taxpayers. And Bartolin needs Colorado Springs to be appealing, to look good, if he's going to attract tourists.
所以，是的。我终于明白了。当香格里拉的首席执行官写了一份宣言时，人们会注意。在该市的黑暗日子里，公园变得枯黄，布罗德莫依然青翠茂盛。史蒂夫·巴托林一直在这里看着科罗拉多斯普林斯市议会在做什么。他很不高兴。布罗德莫是该市最大的纳税人之一。如果他想吸引游客，巴托林需要科罗拉多斯普林斯具有吸引力，看起来不错。
What they had done was say we need a tax increase. The citizens voted it down. So it's one of these things where we'll show you. Now you're not going to have streetlights. And we're not going to water our parks. It seemed ridiculous to me, we can't water our own parks. And that generated a lot of negative publicity on the national level, that we were just rolling up the doormat and closing for business.
他们所做的是说我们需要加税。市民们投票否决了。所以这是一件这样的事，我们会向你们展示。现在你们没有路灯了。我们也不会浇灌我们的公园。这对我来说似乎很荒谬，我们不能浇灌我们自己的公园。这在全国范围内引起了很多负面宣传，说我们只是收起门垫，关门营业了。
And Bartolin thinks to himself, this is certainly not the way you would run a hotel. And then he has this kind of crazy idea, this thought experiment. What if Colorado Springs did run more like the Broadmoor Hotel? Think about it, Bartolin muses. They're both in the same business, providing customer service.
巴托林心想，这当然不是你经营酒店的方式。然后他有了这种疯狂的想法，这种思想实验。如果科罗拉多斯普林斯经营得更像布罗德莫酒店呢？想一想，巴托林思忖。他们都在做同样的生意，提供客户服务。
I look at our business. I mean, we have about the same number of employees as the city. And I look at us as a service delivery organization, that's what we do. How do you deliver the highest quality of service in the most efficient, cost-effective manner? There's an art to doing that. And that was kind of where I was coming from. Maybe there's another way to approach this.
我看看我们的业务。我是说，我们的员工人数和城市差不多。我把我们看作是一个服务交付组织，这就是我们所做的。你如何以最有效、最具成本效益的方式提供最高质量的服务？做这件事是有艺术的。这就是我来的地方。也许有另一种方法来处理这个问题。
Now Bartolin knows there are big differences between a city and a hotel. But he starts looking at the city budget, and looking at the Broadmoor. Back and forth. And writing down actual specific comparisons. Why does the city let employees rack up sick days year after year, he wonders. You'd never do that at the hotel. And why does it take 81 people to run the computer department at the city? There are only nine computer guys at the Broadmoor.
巴托林知道城市和酒店之间有很大区别。但他开始看城市预算，再看布罗德莫。来回对比。并写下实际的具体比较。他想知道，为什么城市允许员工年复一年地积累病假。你在酒店里绝不会那样做。为什么城市需要81个人来运行电脑部门？布罗德莫只有9个电脑人员。
But the biggest difference Bartolin notices between Colorado Springs and the Broadmoor Hotel, the thing that just jumps out at him, is how much Colorado Springs spends on its employees, particularly on health benefits and pensions.
但巴托林注意到科罗拉多斯普林斯和布罗德莫酒店之间最大的区别，那个直接跳进他眼里的东西，是科罗拉多斯普林斯在员工身上花费了多少钱，特别是在健康福利和养老金方面。
They're running a 70% labor cost, and we'll run a 35% labor cost.
他们的劳动力成本占70%，而我们是35%。
Meaning that their employees are twice as much of their budget as they are for you?
意思是他们的员工在预算中所占的比例是你预算的两倍？
Correct. Not saying it should be on an equal basis, but that seemed like quite an extreme. I was shocked. I said, it's over. I mean, you don't have a chance.
正确。不是说应该在平等的基础上，但这似乎是一个相当极端的数字。我很震惊。我说，结束了。我是说，你没机会了。
What do you mean, you don't have a chance?
你说，没机会了，是什么意思？
You can't run an organization with a 70% payroll. Any business person could look at that and say, Jesus, we're going to be out of business in 2014 at this pace.
你不能用70%的工资来运营一个组织。任何商人看一眼都会说，天哪，照这个速度我们2014年就倒闭了。
He writes down all these cost comparisons in an email. A private email, Bartolin stresses, meant only for the people who run the city. He put "City Budget" in the subject line, and he gets specific. The city needs to lower its starting wages. The city should require employees to pay a bigger share of their health insurance costs.
他在一封电子邮件中写下了所有这些成本比较。巴托林强调，这是一封私人的电子邮件，仅供运行这座城市的人看。他在主题行中写了“城市预算”，而且他很具体。市政府需要降低起薪。市政府应该要求员工支付更大份额的医疗保险费用。
And on top of all of this, Bartolin tells the council the city should hire private companies to do the things that it used to do. Contract out everything that is practical, he writes, with sharply negotiated pricing. Now, none of these ideas are new. Privatization is going on all the time in places run by Republicans and by Democrats. But the way Bartolin framed it, it was compelling. And besides, who wouldn't want to live in a world like the Broadmoor? The email reeked of optimism.
最重要的是，巴托林告诉议会，市政府应该雇佣私人公司来做它过去所做的事情。他写道，在 practical（实际）的情况下承包所有事情，并且进行严格的定价谈判。现在，这些想法都不是新的。私有化在共和党人和民主党人经营的地方一直在发生。但巴托林 framing（构架）它的方式非常引人注目。而且此外，谁不想生活在一个像布罗德莫那样的世界里呢？那封邮件里散发着乐观的味道。
I looked at it and I did some editing once I had it drafted. And then I thought, should I send this or not?
我看了看，草拟好之后做了一些编辑。然后我想，我应该发送吗？
Why did you not want to send it?
为什么你不想发送它？
Well, who wants to ruffle feathers? But then again, I thought, hey, it's just going to the council members and the mayor. Maybe this is a perspective they need to hear. Maybe it'll help. And, ah, what the hell, I'd send it.
嗯，谁想惹麻烦？但转念一想，嘿，它只是发给议会成员和市长。也许这是他们需要听到的视角。也许它会有帮助。所以，该死，我还是发了。
I was sitting in my office, and I think I had just gotten my coffee, and an email came across. And I read it, and it was, wow. This is it.
我坐在办公室里，我想我刚拿到咖啡，一封邮件就传了过来。我读了它，那是，哇。就是这个。
This is not the mayor, this is not a city council member, this is in fact Chuck Fowler, a Colorado Springs businessman who barely knew Steve Bartolin. He was one of the thousands of people who read Bartolin's private email after it was forwarded all over the city.
这不是市长，不是市议会议员，事实上这是查克·福勒（Chuck Fowler），一位几乎不认识史蒂夫·巴托林的科罗拉多斯普林斯商人。在巴托林的私人邮件在全城被转发后，他是数千个读到它的人之一。
And I just said, holy cow, I wonder who else has gotten this. And I started making some telephone calls.
我就说，天哪，不知道还有谁收到了这个。我开始打了一些电话。
And had other people gotten it that you know?
你认识的其他人收到了吗？
Yeah. Yeah. In fact, I was late to get it, which I'm not too happy about.
是啊。是啊。事实上，我是最后一个收到的，我对此不太高兴。
Before long, the Colorado Springs Gazette printed the email in full. For the people here fed up with city government, this was the answer. People wrote letters to the editor preaching from the Bartolin text. They demanded the city council act on the advice. Why isn't the city listening to this man, they asked. Why isn't the city being run like a five star hotel?
不久，科罗拉多斯普林斯的《公报》（Gazette）全文刊登了这封邮件。对于这里厌倦了城市政府的人们来说，这就是答案。人们写信给编辑，宣扬巴托林宣言。他们要求市议会采纳这些建议。他们问，为什么市政府不听这个人的话？为什么市政府没有像五星级酒店那样运营？
All of our citizens can't live at the Broadmoor. And all of our citizens, as much as they would like to, it's just not an option to have that quality of life in a community like Colorado Springs.
我们所有的公民不能都住在布罗德莫。而且我们所有的公民，尽管他们很想住，但在像科罗拉多斯普林斯这样的社区，拥有那种生活质量根本不是一个选择。
City councilwoman Jan Martin says she tried to explain. The city has to hire people with a little more training and experience than at a hotel-- city engineers and managers, police officers. Remember, Martin's a fiscal conservative. But weirdly, she found herself defending the size of local government. She says there's reasons the city payroll looks so high. The pay has to be competitive with the other city governments. Otherwise, no one would come to work for Colorado Springs. And the city doesn't control its own pension costs. Those are mandated by the state.
市议员简·马丁说她试图解释。市政府必须雇佣比酒店训练有素、经验丰富的员工——城市工程师和管理人员、警察。记住，马丁是财政保守派。但奇怪的是，她发现自己在为地方政府的规模辩护。她说有原因说明为什么城市工资看起来这么高。薪酬必须与其他的城市政府竞争。否则，没有人会来为科罗拉多斯普林斯工作。而且该市无法控制自己的养老金成本。那些是州强制要求的。
But no matter how much Jan Martin argued, the Bartolin revolution had begun. Chuck Fowler, the guy who was so impressed with the email, started to mobilize his fellow business people. A group began meeting privately in an oak paneled room in a house once owned by the man who built the Broadmoor. They called themselves the city committee. And the committee spent hundreds of hours going through the city's books.
但无论简·马丁怎么争辩，巴托林革命已经开始了。查克·福勒，那个对电子邮件印象深刻的人，开始动员他的商业伙伴。一群人在曾经属于布罗德莫建造者的房子里的一间橡木镶板房间里秘密开会。他们称自己为城市委员会。委员会花了几百个小时查看该市的账簿。
Fowler says they built a database and ran a computer analysis of the budget. They invited city officials in to talk frankly behind closed doors.
福勒说他们建立了一个数据库并对预算进行了计算机分析。他们邀请市政府官员闭门坦率交谈。
We've had a parade of people coming in here including the entire senior staff of the city sitting around this table discussing this.
我们这里来了一群人，包括市里的整个高级职员，坐在桌子旁讨论这个问题。
When you describe this, I can't help but think that this was almost a shadow city council.
当你描述这个时，我禁不住想这几乎就是一个影子市议会。
We consider ourselves to be unpaid consultants to the city and to the elected leaders.
我们认为自己是为市政府和民选领导人服务的无薪顾问。
Their message to the city was clear. Colorado Springs has to do something about the cost of all these city workers. If it doesn't, they said, the city will run out of money in the next decade. One person who heard this message was a commercial real estate agent named Steve Bach. Bach ran for mayor, touting many of the city committee suggestions. Steve Bartolin even threw him a fundraiser at the Broadmoor. And Bach won.
他们给市政府的信息很明确。科罗拉多斯普林斯必须对所有这些城市员工的成本做点什么。如果它不做，他们说，这座城市将在未来十年内没钱。听到这个信息的人之一是一位名叫史蒂夫·巴赫（Steve Bach）的商业房地产经纪人。巴赫竞选市长，兜售许多城市委员会的建议。史蒂夫·巴托林甚至在布罗德莫为他举行了筹款活动。巴赫赢了。
Voters also approved a whole makeover of city government that gave the mayor new powers to hire and fire and veto spending, just like a CEO. Bach's been mayor about nine months now.
选民们还批准了市政府的全面改造，赋予市长雇佣、解雇和否决支出的新权力，就像一个CEO。巴赫做市长九个月了。
I want our city government to be fiscally sustainable for the long term. I want to improve customer service, and I want to retain great employees.
我希望我们的市政府在长期内是财政上可持续的。我希望改善客户服务，我希望留住优秀的员工。
This is sounding a lot like the Broadmoor.
这听起来很像布罗德莫。
Well, they do a good job of that there.
嗯，他们在那方面做得很好。
Bach's trying several things straight out of Bartolin's email. He's making city employees pay more for their health benefits. He's called for a pay freeze. Bach's talking a lot about outsourcing basic city services, too. If something can be done better by a business or a nonprofit, then good riddance. He started to look at how he might contract out the bus system for cheaper, maybe even pay cab drivers to haul around people who don't have cars. The city hospital is up for lease or sale.
巴赫正在尝试几种直接从巴托林电子邮件中拿来的想法。他正在让城市雇员支付更多的健康福利。他呼吁工资冻结。巴赫也在谈论外包基础城市服务。如果某件事可以由企业或非营利组织做得更好，那再好不过了。他开始研究如何能以更便宜的价格外包公交系统，甚至可能支付出租车司机费用来运送没有车的人。市医院即将出租或出售。
The first place you can see this new privatizing agenda in action is the city parks. Last spring they contracted with landscaping firms to mow, edge and trim. So, did it work? What happens when you privatize this guy?
你可以看到这个新的私有化议程付诸行动的第一个地方是城市公园。去年春天，他们与园林绿化公司签约负责修剪、边缘修整和修剪。那么，它奏效了吗？当你私有化这个人时会发生什么？
My name is Roland Hawkins. I live here in Colorado Springs. I'm married, got a 16-year-old boy, got three dogs. And I got a jeep I want to sell. You guys interested?
我叫罗兰·霍金斯（Roland Hawkins）。我住在科罗拉多斯普林斯。我结婚了，有个16岁的男孩，有三只狗。我还有一辆想卖掉的吉普车。你们感兴趣吗？
We visited Roland at his house in a nice old section of Colorado Springs. He leads us through his garage, past the jeep, and into his basement rec room. The walls are lined with thousands of records. And he takes the one easy chair right in the middle.
我们在科罗拉多斯普林斯一个漂亮的老区拜访了罗兰。他带我们穿过他的车库，经过吉普车，进入他的地下室娱乐室。墙上摆满了成千上万张唱片。他坐在中间那把唯一的舒适椅子上。
Roland lays out his whole story. He began as a seasonal worker in the parks, back in the good times, sitting on a mower all day for $7 an hour. Then he got his big break. Full time city employment.
罗兰讲了他整个故事。他一开始是公园的一名季节性工人，回到美好的时光，整天坐在割草机上，每小时7美元。然后他迎来了转机。全职城市雇员。
My pay doubled almost immediately from seasonal to permanent. OK? And then I must have got five raises, which just blew me away. I just couldn't get over it. There'd be one, and then a couple of months later I got another one. I've never worked in a place like that before. It was great. I loved it.
我的工资从季节性变为永久性后几乎立即翻了一番。好吗？然后我一定得到了五次加薪，这让我惊呆了。我简直无法释怀。会有一次，几个月后我又得到了另一次。我从未在那样的地方工作过。那太棒了。我爱死它了。
Why were they giving you raises?
为什么他们给你加薪？
I was good.
我很优秀。
Roland could have been great for all we know. But that didn't matter, because the pay raises he was getting were automatic. I know it seems extreme, but we checked this all with the city. Roland got 10 raises in five years. He went from making $29,000 a year to more than $42,000 a year. 42K. It's not like he's a union member or anything. It's just the way the city worked.
据我们所知罗兰可能很优秀。但这并不重要，因为他得到的加薪是自动的。我知道这看起来很极端，但我们向市政府核实了一切。罗兰在五年内加薪10次。他的年薪从2.9万美元涨到了4.2万美元多。4.2万。他并不是什么工会成员之类的。这只是城市运作的方式。
I knew there was going to be raises, but not in the way they came all of a sudden, man. It was like a landslide. You know? I kept wondering how can you do this? How could this go on? I mean if they're doing it to me, they got to be doing it to the next guy. How long they can do that?
我知道会有加薪，但不是像那样突然来的方式，伙计。就像山崩一样。你知道吗？我一直想知道怎么能这样做？这怎么能持续下去？我是说如果他们对我这样做，他们一定也对下一个人这样做。他们能持续多久？
I guess you thought out the answer.
我想你想出了答案。
Yeah. And that's why you're here talking to me, right?
是的。这就是为什么你在这里跟我谈话，对吧？
His 10th raise was his last. At its height, Colorado Springs' parks budget was more than $19 million. After voters rejected the property tax increase, it was slashed to just $3 million. A month after the vote, Christmas 2009, Roland and dozens of his colleagues were fired.
他的第10次加薪是最后一次。在最鼎盛时期，科罗拉多斯普林斯的公园预算超过1900万美元。在选民否决了房产税增加后，它被削减到仅300万美元。投票后的一个月，2009年圣诞节，罗兰和他的几十名同事被解雇了。
By last summer, the workers had all been replaced. The city came up with some more money to spend on parks, but it went straight to private landscaping companies who could hire their own guys. Guys who weren't going to get all those sweet pay bumps and benefits. So who was the unlucky bastard who took Roland's job for less money?
到去年夏天，工人都被替换了。市政府想出了更多钱花在公园上，但钱直接流向了私人园林绿化公司，他们可以雇佣自己的人。那些不会得到所有那些甜蜜加薪和福利的家伙。那么，谁是那个拿了罗兰的工作换取更少钱的不幸的混蛋呢？
My name is Roland Hawkins, and I got a jeep I want to sell. You guys interested?
我叫罗兰·霍金斯，我有一辆想卖掉的吉普车。你们感兴趣吗？
That's right. Private Roland replaced public Roland.
没错。私人罗兰取代了公共罗兰。
The same thing I was doing for the city. Exactly the same thing. Equipment operator. I was mowing.
我和为市政府做的一样的事情。完全一样。设备操作员。我当时在割草。
How weird is that? You're back doing the same job.
那有多奇怪？你又回去做同样的工作了。
You know what is really weird-- I thought so too, that it was kind of odd. But what was really weird is, I ended up in the district where my old supervisor was. That's the weird part.
你知道什么真的很奇怪——我也这么想，这有点古怪。但真正奇怪的是，我最终落在了我以前主管所在的区。那才是奇怪的部分。
You were working kind of for the same guy, way up above.
你是在为同一个家伙工作，在上面很高的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
Except in a private firm.
除了是在一家私人公司。
Yeah. It was kind of awkward at first.
是的。起初有点尴尬。
We had Roland walk us through the differences between his old job and his new job. We talked to his employers, too. The landscaping firm definitely got Roland to do the same job for a smaller paycheck. They paid him around $17 an hour, rather than the $20 or so he was making at the city. That's $36,000 a year private versus $42,000 a year public.
我们让罗兰带我们看了他旧工作和新工作之间的区别。我们也谈到了他的雇主。园林绿化公司确实让罗兰以更少的工资做同样的工作。他们每小时付给他大约17美元，而不是他在市政府工作时赚的20美元左右。那是私有化年薪3.6万美元，对公共部门年薪4.2万美元。
The private firm was also saving money on benefits. The city, as you might expect, has a great insurance and pension plan. There are lots of variables, but if you spend your career with the city, you can get 70% or even 80% of your salary when you retire. That's pretty sweet. Roland chose not to take benefits from the private landscaping firm, but they do offer them. Medical and retirement after people work there a while. But it's pretty standard stuff.
私人公司在福利上也省钱。市政府，正如你可能预料的那样，有很好的保险和养老金计划。有很多变量，但如果你在市政府工作一辈子，当你退休时，你可以得到工资的70%甚至80%。那非常甜蜜。罗兰选择不从私人园林绿化公司领取福利，但他们确实提供。人们工作一段时间后可以有医疗和退休。但那很标准。
We did a simple calculation with all these numbers. Compared the salaries and added in the typical benefit packages for each job. Roughly here, private Roland is about $12,000 cheaper a year to employ than public Roland was. The city spent $57,000 on him. For the same stuff, all things being equal, the landscaping firm would be out about $45,000. That's a savings of roughly 21% for the same job, remember.
我们用所有这些数字做了一个简单的计算。比较了薪水，并增加了每份工作的典型福利待遇。大体上，雇佣私人罗兰比公共罗兰每年便宜大约12000美元。市政府在他身上花了5.7万美元。对于同样的东西，如果一切条件相同，园林绿化公司大约会花费4.5万美元。那是大约21%的节省，记住是同样的工作。
And Roland? He was OK with working for the private sector. He'd rather be making more money, but he thought, these guys were doing a good job.
罗兰呢？他对为私营部门工作没意见。他宁愿赚更多钱，但他想，这些人做得很好。
Before I got laid off, I always thought, well, a private company's gonna do shortcuts. I was wrong about that. Civilian life is more, let's get out there, let's do it, let's do it. We got stuff to do. And you want to make it look good. You make it look good, you make the company look good. The civilian guy can fire your butt. The city, man, has to go through a long process to fire your butt, and it's hard for them to do that. So you're doing extra. You're doing more. You've got to do more in a civilian.
在我被解雇之前，我总认为，嗯，私人公司会走捷径。我错了。平民生活更多的是，让我们出去，让我们做，让我们做。我们有事要做。而且你想让它看起来不错。你让它看起来不错，你就让公司看起来不错。平民可以解雇你的屁股。市政府，伙计，必须经历漫长的过程才能解雇你，他们很难做到。所以你做得更多。你做得更多。在平民那里你必须做得更多。
Roland was doing more work for less money. That's the dream of privatization, right? But the bigger picture here is more complicated. Remember, Roland isn't the only cost involved. The private landscaping firms add a healthy profit on the top, that's normal. And they had to purchase a lot of the things that the city already had, like equipment.
罗兰用更少的钱做了更多的工作。这就是私有化的梦想，对吧？但这里更大的图景更复杂。记住，罗兰不是唯一的成本。私人园林绿化公司在上面增加了一笔可观的利润，这是正常的。而且他们不得不购买很多市政府已经拥有的东西，比如设备。
So did the city really save any money here by outsourcing, by privatizing Roland's job? We asked the city of Colorado Springs this question over and over again. And they hemmed and they delayed. They couldn't find a number. Then they said it's tough to calculate. In the end, all we could get from the city was this. Outsourcing Roland Hawkins and all those other workers might save money in the future.
那么通过外包、私有化罗兰的工作，市政府真的省钱了吗？我们一次又一次地问科罗拉多斯普林斯市这个问题。他们支支吾吾，拖延时间。他们找不到数字。然后他们说计算起来很困难。最后，我们能从市政府得到的只有这个。外包罗兰·霍金斯和所有那些其他工人可能会在未来省钱。
Because medical costs will rise. Pension costs could also rise. Better to get Roland off the books now, privatize him now. But as for last summer, the first year of the parks experiment, the city couldn't say if they saved a dime.
因为医疗成本会上升。养老金成本也可能上升。最好现在把罗兰从账面上划掉，现在私有化他。但至于去年夏天，公园实验的第一年，市政府无法说他们是否省了一分钱。
Overall, the city's budget for parks is about $12 million now, a lot smaller than it was at its height. But that's mostly because the parks department is doing less. They've closed swimming pools and laid off community center employees. They're replacing fewer playgrounds and fences and bridges. And Roland, for his part? He's not going back to the parks this summer. He hurt his back.
总的来说，该市现在的公园预算大约是1200万美元，比顶峰时期小得多。但这主要是因为公园部门做得更少了。他们关闭了游泳池并解雇了社区中心员工。他们更换的游乐场、围栏和桥梁也少了。罗兰呢？他今年夏天没回公园。他的背受伤了。
What I learned, though, from talking to the people in Colorado Springs is that for a lot of them these calculations don't really matter. They don't care if privatizing actually saves the government money, so long as the government is doing less.
不过，我从与科罗拉多斯普林斯人们的交谈中学到的是，对于他们中的许多人来说，这些计算并不重要。他们不在乎私有化是否真的为政府省钱，只要政府做得更少就行。
City councilwoman Jan Martin says she hears this all the time. That it's become a matter of faith in the city that private is better. And she tells us a story. In the dark days, after the tax measure was defeated, city council was having another meeting about slashing government.
市议员简·马丁说她总是听到这个。在城市里，这已经成为一种信仰，即私有化更好。她告诉我们一个故事。在黑暗日子里，税收法案被否决后，市议会正在召开另一次关于削减政府的会议。
And a gentleman came up to me and actually thanked me for the adopt a street light program. He had just written a check to the city for $300 to turn all the street lights back on in his neighborhood. And I did remind him that for $200 if he had supported the tax initiative, we could have had not only streetlights, but parks and firemen and swimming pools and community centers. That by combining our resources, we as a community can actually accomplish more than we as individuals.
一位绅士走过来，真的感谢我搞了“领养路灯”计划。他刚刚给市政府写了一张300美元的支票，把街区里的所有路灯都重新打开了。我确实提醒他，如果他支持税收倡议，只需200美元，我们不仅可以拥有路灯，还可以拥有公园、消防员、游泳池和社区中心。通过结合我们的资源，作为一个社区，我们实际上可以比作为个人完成更多。
And he said?
然后他说？
He said he would never support a tax increase.
他说他绝不支持加税。
So for him it wasn't the money. He was willing to pay more to turn on the street lights than to pay for all city services.
所以对他来说，这不是钱的问题。他宁愿支付更多的钱来打开路灯，也不愿支付城市服务费用。
That's right. And it's because of a total lack in trust of local government to spend those services, which was part of Steve Bartolin's letter. That prevailing sense that government won't take care of our money, that brings somebody to the conclusion that, I'll take care of mine. You go figure out how to take care of yours, because we don't trust government to do it for us.
没错。这是因为完全不信任地方政府来提供这些服务，这是史蒂夫·巴托林信件的一部分。那种政府不会照顾我们钱的普遍感觉，导致某人得出结论，我会照顾我的钱。你去想办法照顾你的吧，因为我们不信任政府为我们做这件事。
Two years after Colorado Springs went dark, this is where they are. The city looks better. The lights are back on, the parks are green again. But it wasn't because of privatization or the new mayor. Remember how Martin mentioned that sales tax revenue plummets in a recession? It also recovers fast. Tax revenue is bumping back up nicely.
在科罗拉多斯普林斯陷入黑暗两年后，他们到了这一步。城市看起来更好了。灯亮了，公园又绿了。但这不是因为私有化或新市长。还记得马丁提到销售税收入在经济衰退中骤降吗？它也会快速恢复。税收收入正在恢复得很好。
The Colorado Springs experiment in not trusting government is continuing full steam ahead. They're trying to build a city where government does less, costs less, and leaves $200 in your pocket, not the government's.
科罗拉多斯普林斯不信任政府的实验正在全速前进。他们试图建立一个政府做得更少、成本更低、把200美元留在你口袋里而不是政府口袋里的城市。
Robert Smith is a member of our Planet Money team. Planet Money is a co-production of our program and NPR News. Their blog and podcast, npr.org/money.
罗伯特·史密斯是我们Planet Money团队的成员。《Planet Money》是我们节目和NPR新闻的联合制作。他们的博客和播客，npr.org/money。
[MUSIC -  "OPTIMISM BLUES" BY HELEN REDDY]
[音乐 - 海伦·雷迪（Helen Reddy）的“乐观蓝调”（Optimism Blues）]
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International, WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. I was just talking to him. He bought this aquarium and some fish as pets. But he is not into them.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播（PRI）发行，我们的节目管理监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。我刚和他谈过。他买了水族箱和一些鱼作为宠物。但他并不喜欢它们。
I think they're rude, they're ignorant. They're not friendly. Do you know what I mean?
我认为它们很粗鲁，很无知。它们不友好。你知道我的意思吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播。